oh
[Musique]
c'est comme un hymne à la joie pour ses
trente sept musiciens du bonheur pour ce
retour sur scène pendant le dernier
week-end du mois d'août lors qu'istres
les dissonances dirigé par david grimal
a célébré ludwig van beethoven les notes
du virtuose allemand ont résonné dans la
grange de port royal des champs de magny
les hameaux pour célébrer les 250 ans de
sa naissance
[Musique]
pour les musiciens en ce moment c'est
terrible on vit une période inédite dans
l'histoire on est vraiment privé de
notre métier donc pour la plupart des
musiciens qui sont ici c'est le premier
concert en hors caisse depuis six mois
faut quand même se rendre compte des
choses et donc je crois que c'est cette
fraternité cette joie de se retrouver
que j'ai voulu mettre en avant
on va jouer deux serveurs et de baies
tough ce soir qui sont deux symphonies
qui sont moins jouer qui sont parmi les
moins joué en fait et qui sont
absolument génial et donc on s'est dit
qu'on allait à partager avec le public
ses chefs-d'oeuvre qu'ils connaissent un
peu moins plusieurs symphonie
interprétée par cet orchestre pour mêler
le patrimoine historique de saint
quentin en yvelines avec la musique
classique
c'était l'idée de pouvoir présenter
beethoven dans le cadre d'une sorte de
festival en plein air d'été avec la
possibilité de permettre au public
d'avoir des ateliers de pouvoir manger
sur place et profiter de la musique
prochain rendez vous musical au musée
national de port royal des champs le
samedi 19 septembre
béatrice martin au clavecin viendra
interpréter le répertoire de jean
sébastien bach
[Musique]
on